not every trilogy goes as planned and
some never even make it to the finish
line
maybe they bombed at the box office
perhaps they were savaged by critics or
maybe there was behind-the-scenes drama
whatever the reason these movie
trilogies were stopped in their tracks
and will never be completed Sony
Pictures saw dollar signs in the popular
millennium series by the late Swedish
novelist and journalist Stieg Larsson
and assembled an all-star cast and crew
to make a movie David Fincher was
perfectly suited for this dark sordid
material while Daniel Craig and Rooney
Mara seamlessly brought main characters
be kale Blomkvist and Lisbeth Salander
to life The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
won rave reviews from critics but it
wasn't a runaway hit earning 102 million
dollars domestically and 232 million
dollars worldwide on a 90 million dollar
budget in 2011 Sony wanted to cut costs
on the sequel but Daniel Craig fresh off
sky falls global gross of 1 billion
dollars wanted a raise as a result the
studio squashed any hopes of Amara and
Craig trilogy instead Sony opted to go
with an entirely new cast seven years
later with the 2018 sequel the girl in
the spider's web casting Claire Foy as
Lisbeth and spire goodness and as Mikael
but not even the film's modest 43
million dollar budget could save it with
the film earning only 14 million dollars
domestic and 35 million dollars
worldwide gross with Tom Cruise in the
title role the original Jack Reacher
film about an ex-military policeman
wasn't above average crime thriller
earning a 63% tomato meter score and 217
million dollars worldwide on a 60
million dollar budget
however the sequels subtitle never go
back unintentionally served as a warning
as it earned a 37 percent tomato meter
score and 159 million dollars worldwide
on a 60 million dollar budget still
profitable but a troubling 27 percent
drop while series creator Lee Child had
nothing but nice things to say about
cruise as a person he agreed with
readers that the 5 foot 7 inch cruise
wasn't the right fit for the towering
character and the series stalled out
released in 2014
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles was no
slow-moving tortoise earning 485 million
dollars worldwide on a 125 million
dollar budget paramount was feeling
confident so they upped the budget for
2016 Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out of
the
- 135 million dollars but this time the
turtles only brought 245 million dollars
worldwide a 50% drop that made this over
budgeted follow-up a box office bomb
paramount wasn't going to make the same
mistake as New Line Cinema did with the
first turtle series back in the 90s and
the studio pulled the plug before making
a third film in late 2016 and reform one
of the film's producers told Collider I
don't think there's Turtles three but I
wouldn't say there's never going to be
another turtles movie in the wake of the
Lord of the Rings and Harry Potter film
success fantasy novels seem to be as hot
a property as comic book adaptations one
of the surefire winners seem to be
Philip Pullman's His Dark Materials a
grim epic that had everything a fantasy
fan could ever want there was just one
issue His Dark Materials has a storyline
that is unapologetically anti-catholic
that has Hema state that is the truth
New Line Cinema the studio that had
brilliantly guided Lord of the Rings
into the record books also thought it
was a good call to release this anti
religion fable during the Christmas
holiday season leaving one to wonder if
any studio executives had even read what
they were buying while the Golden
Compass film was stripped of the books
anti religious themes its reputation
took root and the film was protested by
Christian groups however it's biggest
sin among non-religious moviegoers was
that it was just plain bad with a 42%
tomato meter score on an epic 180
million dollar budget it earned just
seventy million dollars domestic and
three hundred and seventy two million
dollars worldwide putting the nail in
the film trilogies coffin there have
been a lot of James Bond movies at least
25 depending what you count is a Bond
film Sean Connery and Roger Moore played
the character seven times while Pierce
Brosnan portrayed bond four times and
Daniel Craig's fifth appearance as
double-oh-seven is in no time to die
Timothy Dalton was set to get three and
in formal trilogy in the larger series
but only got two Dalton's third film
what would have been the 18th film in
the official series never came to pass
despite its reputation as a franchise
killer licensed to kill made 34 million
dollars domestically and a modestly
profitable 156 million dollars worldwide
on a 42 million dollar budget
Dalton was all set to return for his
third and final Bond film which was set
to feature a British Chinese villain
using the
of nuclear meltdowns to force the
British to return Hong Kong to China
however legal hang-ups halted
pre-production for years by 1994 Dalton
finally dropped out it may have been the
best thing for the franchise since gold
and I made 356 million dollars worldwide
launching Brosnan's highly successful
run as the super spy while speeds
pedal-to-the-metal premise powered it to
121 million dollars domestic and 283
million dollars worldwide on a 30
million dollar budget star Keanu Reeves
passed on the sequel a decision he said
landed him in movie Jail with Fox for
years
Reeves co-star Sandra Bullock returned
for speed to cruise control with Jason
Patric replacing Reeves as her super cop
boyfriend and William Dafoe giving speed
villain Dennis Hopper a run for his
money as a scenery-chewing bad guy alas
patrick was no Reeves plus the movie was
really really bad speed to cruise
control sank earning 48 million dollars
domestic and 150 million dollars
worldwide on a 110 million dollar budget
a 47 percent drop from the first film
Reeves indicated in 2014 he'd be
interested in returning for speed 3 but
after the John wick franchise took off
Reeves seems to have decided that
reprising his roles in the matrix 4 and
Bill and Ted 3 are a safer bet based on
the popular young adult book series
Percy Jackson and the Olympians the
lightning thief follows a teenager who
discovers he's descended from a Greek
god my father's Poseidon god of the Seas
critics gave it a mediocre 50% tomato
meter score but it's released during the
normally non-competitive February
powered the family film to an 88 million
dollar domestic 223 million dollar
worldwide take a narrow victory on a 95
million dollar budget
critics were even less impressed with
2013's Percy Jackson sea of monsters
striking it down with a 42 percent
tomato meter score despite shaving 5
million dollars off the first film's
budget Sea of Monsters only managed 68
million dollars domestically and two
hundred million dollars worldwide even
worse it's 14 million dollar opening
weekend was less than half the first
film's 31 million dollars indicating a
major drop in audience interest star
Logan Lerman told the independent in
2014 that he'd be happy to return for a
third film but eventually confirmed in
2020 that Percy Jackson 3 wouldn't be
happening instead the franchise will
soon be moving to the small screen with
a television series distributed by the
Disney Plus streaming platform while
2006 is Silent Hill did OK at the box
office it still only managed an
atrocious 31% tomato meter score its
earnings were on par for other horror
films bringing in 46 million dollars
domestically and 94 million dollars
worldwide but it's inexplicably high 50
million dollar budget put its
profitability in doubt it would be
another six years before 2012 Silent
Hill revelation 3d arrived to a
downright disastrous 20% tomato meter
score while open road films wisely spent
just 20 million dollars this time making
a sequel six years after a mediocre
first film is rarely a wise decision
Silent Hill revelation 3d earned a mere
17 million dollars domestically and 55
million dollars worldwide a 42 percent
drop from the first film though
ironically it was probably more
profitable given the much smaller budget
while a trilogy was never announced fans
held out hope until Silent Hill
revelation 3d broke their hearts
director MJ Bassett even apologized
saying of the sequel it was just a
nightmare dance and I couldn't do it so
I'm very sorry to everyone who didn't
like the movie in 1994 Stargate
seamlessly blended science fiction with
Egyptian mythology the film was a
surprising hit setting a new October
opening weekend box office record at the
time with sixteen million dollars
eventually earning 71 million dollars
domestic and 196 million dollars
worldwide filmmakers Roland Emmerich and
Dean Devlin had originally planned a
trilogy of films with each movie
focusing on a different mythology
however instead of continuing with
Stargate the duo parlayed their success
into one of the biggest hits of the 90s
with Independence Day meanwhile MGM put
the Stargate film series on hold thanks
to the success of the TV series which
started in 1997 with Stargate sg-1 12
years after the original film Devlin
revealed plans for a sequel at 2006 is
San Diego comic-con but it would be
another eight years before a new
Stargate was announced this time as a
remake however the failure of
Independence Day resurgence in 2016
killed any interest in reviving Emmerich
in Devlin's other 1990 sci-fi property
and the Stargate trilogy was officially
cancelled in 2018 the Tim Burton and
Joel Schumacher Batman franchise broke
the opening weekend rack
three times but neither set of films
ever got a proper send-off sure while
all four films are technically part of
the same series they feel like two
different franchises as each director
started strong but went off the rails in
their second film after moviegoers
rejected each directors second film
neither one got to complete his trilogy
while Tim Burton never got to the
scripting stage on Batman 3 rumors
circulated that Michelle Pfeiffer was
returning his Catwoman and Robin
Williams was set to play the Riddler
however after Batman Returns terrified
children and dropped 36 percent from
Batman's worldwide gross Burton was
politely asked not to return and Michael
Keaton bailed Joel Schumacher brought
the series back to his record-breaking
ways with Batman Forever in 1995
following the film's success Warner
Brothers started planning a third
schumacher Batman movie before the
sequel Batman and Robin was even
released however Batman and Robin's
critical and commercial failure in 1997
put Batman back in the cave for eight
years until Christopher Nolan rebooted
the series yet again with Batman Begins
boosted by strong reviews the 1984
classic comedy horror hybrid gremlins
became a huge surprise hit earning 153
million dollars worldwide to become
1984's fourth highest-grossing movie
later in 1990 gremlins - the new batch
earned a respectable amount of critical
praise but the Mogwai magic had worn off
and the film only made forty-one million
dollars
the gremlin franchise was put on ice for
decades but screenwriter Chris Columbus
said gremlins 3 was on its way in 2018
and would be a full reboot in April 2020
The Hollywood Reporter said that a new
gremlins was indeed set to arrive on HBO
max but would presumably be a series so
while we do expect there to be more
gremlins in the future a third film in
the original franchise might never see
the light of day
Austrian bodybuilder Arnold
Schwarzenegger was catapulted to
worldwide fame as an action star with
1982's Conan the Barbarian which earned
thirty eight million dollars
domestically and 79 million dollars
worldwide on a 20 million dollar budget
Conan what is best in life to crush your
enemies see them driven before you they
had a lamentation of the women a sequel
was pushed into production yet despite
its lower 18 million dollar budget Conan
the Destroyer proved Conan was a
one-hit-wonder bombing with
six million dollars worldwide in the
summer of 1984 The Terminator became a
massive hit just a few months later
making Schwarzenegger one of the biggest
stars of the 80s after terminator
Schwarzenegger passed on making Conan 3
but a few decades later the former
governor of California sought to make
the legend of conan playing the
barbarian as an aged king when that
project died a grisly death an amazon
series was announced but that was also
scrapped with Arnold claiming the rights
holders were the issue while
screenwriter Chris Morgan hoped to
breathe new life into Conan 3 the poor
box-office performance of Terminator
dark fate stalled any hope for
Schwarzenegger nostalgia projects I
won't be back check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]